the colin kaepernick story isn't going
away as much as the nfl would like it to
do so there was a report from matt
burrows of the athletic on monday taking
season with the 49ers now
part of the false narratives that have
been
circulating for the last three and a
half years
focus on
2016. focus on kaepernick's performance
that year there's
a screenshot from espn that gets used by
the people who are anti-kaepernick to
suggest he wasn't good in 2016. people
will say he was benched for blaine
gabbert in 2016. that
is just flat out false as false
narratives go it's one of the most false
what happened was after the 2015 season
colin kaepernick had three different
surgeries
and
he was recovering from those surgeries
throughout the off-season
and he wasn't ready to be the starter he
wasn't even in uniform for the first
couple of preseason games one of the
reasons people didn't notice he was
sitting for the national anthem is
because he wasn't dressed he didn't play
he wasn't even in position to play in
the first couple of preseason games it
wasn't until he was in uniform and
people saw his name across the back of
the jersey his number seven sitting on
the bench that even became an issue in
late august of 2016.
so
he didn't lose the job to blame gabbard
blaine gabbert was healthy
and then
when the 49ers
benched blaine gabbard for a
finally healthy colin kaepernick jeremy
curley who ended up being the leading
receiver on the team that year
said that
kaepernick energized the offense and he
ultimately threw 16 touchdown passes
against four interceptions and i know
that the 49ers only had one win
while kaepernick started that year but
look
the same people who are going to shout
and scream that quarterback wins don't
count when a team wins a lot of games so
we think the quarterback is better than
his numbers would indicate those same
people need to acknowledge that if the
team doesn't win games with the
quarterback on the field that shouldn't
be an indictment of his overall
performance either they had a lot of
injuries that year chip kelly was the
wrong choice for head coach they were
going through a lot of transition and
dysfunction remember it was the third of
three straight years that saw the coach
get fired at the end of the season jim
harbaugh fired or mutual parting after
the 2014 season jim harbaugh has since
said that baloney he was fired
jim tomsula one and done fired after
2015 chip kelly one and done fired after
2016. so
the idea that kaepernick
stunk in 2016 isn't supported by the
evidence now at times at times
in 2015 and 2016 after he signed that
big contract he wasn't as good as he had
been early in his career
but
when a guy goes from being
a franchise quarterback
a guy that ron jaworski once said on
espn and created like a week of content
as they churned it and churned it the
kaepernick could be one of the best
quarterbacks ever
when he goes from that
to
middle of a pack mediocre at best
if we accept that premise it doesn't
mean that the end result is he's out of
the league altogether
jameis winston
isn't out of the league he's the backup
in new orleans marcus mariota isn't out
of the league he's the backup with the
raiders
there would have been should have been
could have been an opportunity to be a
backup somewhere for colin kaepernick if
he wasn't blackballed by the nfl and
that's really the broader point and we
can
debate
all we want the question of whether or
not
the nfl
collectively shunned colin kaepernick
the evidence suggests that it did and
the fact that the nfl eventually paid
out
a sum reportedly between five and ten
million dollars to sell his collusion
claim
suggests that the nfl which
has a pretty long track record of
winning in court and also a pretty long
track record of not giving in
unless there's a reason to give in there
was a reason to give it
and remember
they didn't buy out colin kaepernick's
employment rights when they settled that
grievance in early 2019. he could still
file another collusion grievance against
the nfl if he wanted to i don't know
that he wants to
i do know that he wants to play though
and i continue to be astounded by
this current posture
as we addressed over the weekend
remember when the nfl initially said
via nfl media
that there are multiple teams interested
in colin kaepernick we reported to pft
well none of them have reached out to
kaepernick or his agents well the volley
then from the nfl via nfl media was the
teams are talking to friends and
associates of colin kaepernick well
kaepernick's camp has first of all no
idea who these friends and associates
are and the way it was touched by nfl
media
was something like this
that
they're going to do their homework
without talking to kaepernick or his
agents until they get to the point where
they're reasonably comfortable that they
can sign capital to a contract at that
point they'll talk to the agent which
makes no sense
because and i know this is high level
negotiation strategy
but
one of the ways you get comfortable
with your ability to sign a player to a
contract
is
to
talk
to
his
agent
so none of it makes any sense now the
best argument i think
in support of whatever it is the nfl's
doing and it's not an argument that
makes it right it's an argument that
helps us understand where they're coming
from i really do think
there's kind of a loose effort here to
run out the clock
to
feign interest
in colin kaepernick until the attention
of the media and the fans moves on to
something else maybe whether or not
we're going to have football at all this
year
if we can just
if we it's not exactly good news for the
nfl hey if we can just delay this story
until the point where all anyone is
talking about is whether we're going to
be able to play games this year
we win
well you don't
but that may be what they're doing
because as we'll discuss in a few
minutes i feel like we are getting
closer and closer to the point where
some tough conversations need to be had
about whether or not football is even
possible given where the pandemic
currently is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports